[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and that was a big part
of the opening scene for doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness this scene
is epic and we actually have a
description of the first 25 minutes of
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness that was shown during cinemacon
that goes along with this footage so if
you're wondering what exactly is
happening in this scene we'll break it
down but we'll also give you the parts
before it and a few parts that come
after it and why exactly america chavez
is there fighting with doctor strange in
the first place so a lot to break down
and talk about today and big thank you
to better help for sponsoring this video
more in them in a bit now actually to
start off for the moon night fans it
looks like we might have discovered the
official run time for the finale episode
and if these reports are true it's only
42 minutes making it the shortest moon
night episode we've had yet so i'm a
little worried but i really really hope
that they nail the ending here we'll
have to wait and see but let's talk
about the 25 minutes of footage that was
shown at cinemacon this lines up with
this clip that was released as well this
description was provided by
comicbook.com who had some people there
at cinemacon so thank you to them for
that this is what it says about the
footage that was shown for doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
and i have to warn you there are some
spoilers in this again it's only the
first 25 minutes so nothing about the
illuminati or anything like that but
some spoilers end this so you've been
warned the movie picks up with the demon
chasing america chavez and defender
strange this guy's a bit of a prick and
gets killed but america manages to
escape to our mcu cut to doctor strange
waking up and thinking it was all a
dream he then goes to christine's
wedding where he's confronted about the
blip and his role in what happened by
michael stolbarg was there really only
one way to beat thanos he asks strange
and christine talk at the bar he regrets
not making her a priority she wants to
introduce him to her husband strange is
interrupted by schumache arriving in
downtown new york and raymie really
wastes no time strange leaps into action
and saves chavez and wong joins him all
three team up to battle the monster in a
magic field fight it's pretty great and
in case you don't know sam raimi is of
course the director of this film and he
also directed the first tobey maguire
spider-man trilogy
after the monster is defeated the three
head to get some food where america
introduces herself and tells them that
she's being hunted there's a funny bit
where doctor strange explains spider-man
to her who apparently doesn't exist in
her home universe knowing home made a
huge impact on the mcu but it is
interesting that he mentions spider-man
so we'll have to come back and break
that down as well but to continue on
with the scene the main goal seems to be
to find the book of ashanti which wang
knows exists because he's the sorcerer
supreme taking a dig at his pal dr
strange they soon come to realize it's
witchcraft and they need more help so
strange seeks out wanda wanda is also
dreaming of her kids one division
flashback basically but no vision she
wakes up and is sad and has a sad moment
before she goes out to her field to cut
the tree that is seen in the trailer she
and doctor strange then talk about the
multiverse and he asks for her help and
that is the beginning of the movie the
very very beginning of the movie that's
probably not even 25 minutes it's
probably around 15 to 20 minutes but
there's actually a lot to talk about
here including that spider-man reference
which i'm personally really really happy
that they're going to talk about because
that was obviously a huge thing that
happened in no way home which was kind
of a doctor strange movie as well but it
looks like helping peter parker actually
caused more problems even at the end by
making everybody forget who he was it
looks like there are still some big
repercussions and it looks like this is
kind of what mordo and some members of
the illuminati are going to be going
after doctor strange for this is why
he's going to be in so much trouble with
the illuminati we've basically heard in
some trailers that strange messed with
the multiverse and he's messed with kind
of the fate of a lot of different things
in the first teaser trailer we even
heard the repeat of his words there was
no other way implying that maybe what he
did in avengers in-game with the time
stone wasn't that cool either so what
does this mean for doctor strange and
what does it mean for spider-man we'll
talk about that but first please allow
me to thank our sponsors and thank you
to better help for sponsoring this video
as we all know life can get pretty
hectic sometimes and it's pretty easy to
feel overwhelmed and anxiety whether
it's work school family or relationships
sometimes you just want somebody to talk
to that's where better help comes in if
you feel like you need somebody to talk
to or you just need to check up on your
mental health better help is an online
resource that allows you to do just that
connecting with a therapist online from
the comfort of your home they have a
broad range of officially licensed
therapists over 20 000 therapists in
their network which makes it very
convenient to find a therapist that
works for you and you can change
therapists at any time for free i know
it can be a lot easier to receive
therapy from the comfort of your own
environment and it's not just therapy
sessions you can message your therapist
at any time check out some information
that may be useful to you and schedule
your appointments all from the same page
head to betterhelp.com cosmic wonder to
answer a few questions and get paired up
with a therapist within 48 hours you'll
also get 10 off your first month by
clicking the link in the description
down below that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p-com cosmic wonder
now we know in spider-man knowing home
other people who knew who spider-man
were were coming through the multiverse
from their other universes and at the
end it did seem like doctor strange may
have solved everything by just simply
making everybody forget who peter parker
was and it looks like that worked but
also didn't work because as this says
there's a funny bit where doctor strange
explains spider-man to her who
apparently doesn't exist in her home
universe no way home made a huge impact
on the mcu now originally as i read this
i go okay well he knows who spider-man
is that doesn't necessarily know that he
knows that peter parker is spider-man
but since doctor strange is kind of in
trouble for the events that took place
in no way home i'm assuming something
did not go all the way right in fact
doctor strange even said in no way home
he told peter he didn't even go to the
dean or anybody at the university to
plead his case before he had him alter
the minds of millions and millions and
billions of people which eventually
doctor strange did do and if you're the
illuminati that's probably not okay
especially if you're only doing it for
one person so i'm sure this is going to
be addressed somehow but i am really
curious on whether he knows peter parker
is spider-man or not or if he just knows
who spider-man is because remember the
spell had everybody forget who peter
parker was spider-man should still exist
in the universe even though it seems
like the universe that america chavez
comes from doesn't have one now as we've
been talking about for a while this says
that doctor strange defender strange
dies and it looks like we've pretty much
seen that scene now from the tv spots
defender strange and america chavez are
in a crazy world they're fighting some
crazy ribbon monster and they fall
through a portal but it does kind of
look like defender strange is dead as he
falls through the portal probably
sacrificing himself to protect america
chavez so the fact that he dies in the
very beginning of the movie isn't that
much of a surprise to me however i do
think we might see another variant that
is kind of just like him in another
universe now really the biggest thing i
want to talk about here is the book of
the vashanti because it seems like that
is actually going to set up a battle
between the book of the vashanti and the
darkhold which wanda has you could view
the book of the vishanti as kind of the
opposite of the darkhold the book of the
vishanti contains the most powerful
white magic spells known and many of
them can counter other magical spells in
fact the book itself can actually be
used to deflect magic it has numberless
pages as you read the pages just kind of
appear out of nowhere however the spells
and the magic that you learn from the
book can only be used for defense never
for offense so this book is probably
going to be how they counter the scarlet
witch in multiverse of madness and this
will most likely how they bring wanda
back from let's say the dark side and
perhaps save her at least i hope that's
the case i hope she doesn't continue to
be evil i hope doctor strange with the
help of the book of the vashanti and
wong in american chavez can save our
girl finally but fortunately we don't
have that much longer to wait until we
finally see what happens in doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
about a week to go now for most people
seeing it on may 5th so let me know what
you think about this opening in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos and
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching woof